عيد ميلاد سعيد ، دكتور فوسي ، شكراً
جزيلاً لك
[موسيقى]
عيد ميلاد سعيد لك عيد ميلاد سعيد ،
هل فكرت يومًا أنه في
عيد ميلادك الثمانين
سيكون العالم في هذا الموقف
لم أكن أتوقع حقًا
أنه في عيد ميلادي الثمانين
كن عميقًا في محاولة
التعامل مع
جائحة عالمية ذات أبعاد تاريخية ومعالجتها ،
هل تعتقد أنك ستتقاعد جيدًا في أي وقت ،
أعتقد أنني يجب أن أكون
واقعيًا وأعتقد أنني سأفعل ذلك عاجلاً أم آجلاً.
لا أرى
ذلك الآن بوضوح في مستقبلي ، الشيء الوحيد
الذي أراه في
المستقبل هو التحدي الذي
نواجهه حاليًا ،
هل تعمل 24 7 وليس 24
7 ولكن أكثر مثل 18 7.
لا يوجد يوم عطلة واحد في ما يقرب من عام في
العمر 80.
هل يرتديها عليك جيدًا ، أتخيل
أنه
لا ينتبه إلى ما
يرتديه أنا ،
أعتقد أنه في بعض الأحيان أشعر
بالإرهاق حقًا ولكنك تعلم أنك
تستمر في ذلك